hey guys welcome to the behind the
scenes for the division now this is a
very special project for us is actually
one of the biggest projects we've ever
done a series of four short films across
four channels that we produce so you
might be wondering what this whole
division thing is you might have seen it
on rocketjump or definite sequel trevor
Ubisoft's channel even our own yeah you
never know about two years ago at e3 we
were like no it's a cool game the
division that's a really cool game so we
told some of our friends who work that
you stop that and like cool game they're
like thanks I've got an idea like what
and they're like what if this one was
official and you guys actually made
something that's officially in the world
of division and it's an official
live-action division piece yeah really
that's pretty neat because of the scale
of content we were also doing we decided
to actually produce more of this three
of the episodes you'll notice are
directed by our good friend Adrian
picardy and also one of the episodes is
also directed by our good friend Devin
Graham let me tell you a little about
Adrian so Sam and I have been making
videos together for 16 years now so like
that we started we're like 14 we will
occasionally enter online competitions
and there's always this one freaking guy
that would beat us in every competition
Sam being the ever smart businessman was
like you know what let's reach out and
see if he wants to be our friend
I like video games that's cool I like
video games too we have so much in
common it was cooler than that but
Adrian Niko and myself all sat down and
tried to think of four of the coolest
stories we could tell in the universe of
the division the game takes place in
Manhattan and Manhattan's pretty
expensive to shoot in it's also very
hard to actually find snow in Manhattan
you have to be there for a very specific
time yeah Minnesota a lot easier to find
snow a lot easier to shoot in so he's
shot in the Twin Cities it was really
awesome being able to go back to a place
where we've made so many cool videos and
content and all that stuff and finally
draw from our network of friends and
co-workers and colleagues out there to
make a fully-fledged
production team to tackle project of
this size well start with the episode on
Ubisoft channel there's one key scene in
this episode and that is the gunfight in
the street and that was intense
actually doesn't both Sam and I were on
set for that day helping Adrian run the
show we had an interesting challenge
going into that gunfight
that we hit the street the day of start
parking cars and were like well how does
this gunfight Koch's we need to figure
it out now Sam went down to Windham is
one end of the street and looked around
he channeled all his airsoft game
memories it was like what if these
people in there and they went there and
they shot this person they did this then
Adrian and I ran down the street and we
watched Sam run around and be crazy for
a second and then we have started
inputting some ideas and in about the
span of maybe 30 to 45 minutes we
choreographed the entire gunfight
together that's how you do it
yeah episode 2 aka Devon's baby so
approaching our second episode here
about Everts character basically we
wanted to create something that would
really work for Devon his audience you
know when you're looking at a game like
the division it's all about military
tactical gunfights and like really crazy
dark survivalist stories and stuff like
that and one of the challenges with
Devon's video is needed to write a video
that didn't really have violence but
still had action because that's
something that Devon tries to do with
this channel I try to keep things a
little bit on the lighter side of life
which is cool so there's a really fun
experience to try writing a video that
fit that mood on set though totally
different experience because that was
one of the snowiest shoots and one of
the coldest shoots of the entire four we
had some of the lowest temperatures
everyone was freezing their booties off
despite that though the footage does
look really cool you can see all the
snow in the beginning you can see all
like the steam and breath coming up
people's not all that stuff it looks
incredible
Devon has a penchant for having a moving
camera in all his shots this was the
first time I at least got to see Devon
use that technique of having his
glidecam always flowin episode 3 aka
rumbling in my Tumtum mm-hmm that's the
one cut line from it which I recon
stantly regret yet stay on time this was
actually us actually trying to figure
out a way to make this series a little
more funny looking at all these episodes
we try and make sure that each one kind
of has a little bit of a different genre
you know the third one obviously has
that mood words we are trying to do a
little comedy here whereas we're not
doing that in
so so I highly recommend watching
Rocketship's video after you've watched
any of the other ones because it starts
to play around with some of the in jokes
of the division world
alright so episode flamethrower we may
be save the best episode for our channel
I don't know it depends on what people
like I'm sure every has their preference
you can say that but you can also say
like we're making content that we're
trying to make it good but we're also
understanding you know these are living
on other people's channels so they need
to represent the people who are hosting
them so I guess what we represent our
channel by dark horror filled burnin
ated bodies okay so in the game there's
these guys called the cleaners and
they've been in tons of like the e3 and
gameplay coverage and probably seen him
if you're following the game we decided
alright this is like super messed up and
crazy we're like you know what let's say
that one because it's really intense and
we know that if we pull it off we'll
have no trouble
you know posting it so we were looking
for a flame thrower some of those things
works like you think in the world of
movies flame throwers right people just
make him right ya know so it turns out
that the guys who did the effects in the
battlefield commercial that we made back
in the day with Freddy and Brandon they
actually bought the flamethrower
from lethal weapon 4 and that old flame
thrower doesn't have any of those
limiters in it and they also had old
tanks from like the 70s that didn't have
the limiters in it so they were all set
up to do a legit propane flamethrower
and man that thing kicked fire bar the
thing was so loud when you shot of it
you would hear windows rattle so we're
shooting in another alleyway and the
door kicks open and this dude is
standing there just like ready to go he
has almost extendable metal batons did
he come out and going when it's pretty
rare I'm out ready to reveal it and like
ready to like break some skulls what I
looked around and there's like 20 or so
crew members that all turn and look at
him like these dudes needs PP costumes
and like just this moment of confusion
on his face where's like what the heck
did I walk in Jews got the flamethrowers
like hello-o so we had this little
technique that we now call the division
ticket yeah a new technique was invented
from this project so when you're doing a
gunfight and you need two bullet hits
well who's squibs this time consuming
hard doing dust balls for a paintball
gun its timing timing card what's not is
you take dust and little bits of debris
or paper or whatever you want
and you stand around the corner and you
just flick it and you flick it from
around the corner and it works great and
for that whole apartment fight scene
that's all we did just flung dust from
around corners we would literally just
take that bag hand out handfuls and we
just sit there and go the more people
you have the better it looks all in all
this is one of the biggest products
we've ever done
big thanks to Devon the guys at
rocketjump has an ubisoft adrian jake
everybody in Minnesota this project
turned out amazing it would have been
possible without the culmination of
everybody coming together to make
something cool thank you guys for
watching holy has filled you in a little
bit on what you are looking at and where
this thing dropped from out of nowhere
it's great to finally release it for
everybody to see go check out the other
videos and the other channels and let us
know you thought yeah my only regret is
that the bigger projects get the less we
can talk about them my only regret is
that we didn't use the line my tum-tums
on rambling my Tumtum is irrelevant well
it's become a phrase so yeah don't worry
about it